the Joe Rogan experience great while you
sent that sound great I'm glad that
people are seeing me Neal Brennan sighs
whatever e1 will be a notary notary
public I wonder if they can live there's
a software they can listen to the sound
your pen is making and figure out the
lines you're drawing you know they have
technology now where when people are
speaking in a room with a with a window
they can get rid of the window noise
they can know they can tune into the
vibrations of the window from the sound
of your voice and pick up everything
that's being said in the room I heard
that there's a net flick you because
before I mean efflux doesn't give people
ratings but there's a way that there you
can get they can gauge reflections off
of with some weird [ __ ] technology
where and it's fairly accurate
reflections off a window yes
I don't know second hand yeah like
second it not it's like I believe it's
sound waves oh wow yeah that what are
they monitoring Jamie's got some I have
no idea why this right now Jamie
long-range laser listening device the
long-range laser listening device laser
microscope is a highly sophisticated
surveillance apparatus that utilizes an
invisible infrared laser beam to
eavesdrop on a target this is the most
effective long-range laser listening
device in the world that allows the
operator to conduct an undetectable
surveillance operation on any target
from today Stark Industries with at
least one window at an impressive
distance of over 500 meters that is
actually very impressive are that's far
as [ __ ] with the laser beam [ __ ] and you
just buy that as I say that's
commercially available and I wonder what
is not commercially available oh for
sure it's right out there like you
remember when there was that story about
some weird sound weapon they think that
the Cubans using on ya means that were
in Cuba there's probably a bunch of [ __ ]
like I was reading an article they can
list like submarines have technology
they can listen to basically like fish
farting in the ocean if they if they
wanted to they can hear sounds that
quiet they can
anything so if like literally a fish
parts they're like what was that what
was that was that a sub nope was a fish
was the next sound yeah good for us or
something I guess it's for somebody good
for us I guess yeah that sound thing was
funny cuz it was like people would get
sick yeah and they could and then it
there was also they did in China too
they would like they at American civil
like NGO like non-government they're
like kind of work for the government
tangentially or they worked at the
Embassy their apartments were above each
other to separate people and both of
them it was on 60 minutes like not long
ago like so they targeted the rooms yeah
it's like a dog whistle for people it
yes in essence and it's like well what
do you want me to do I guess you just
leave I guess it is like a dog was I
just want you to feel just sure yeah the
[ __ ] out of here oh yeah there's
probably a ton of technology like that
that we're not aware of my friend Mike
Swick used to fight in the UFC and
before that he did a brief spent stint
rather in the military he was doing
something some sort of he is either
Secret Service work or something along
those lines but anyway he was at the
Embassy in Russia and he said that they
had found listening devices that were so
sophisticated that they were being
powered by the natural sway of the
building Wow with the wind so the wind
they didn't need a power source the
natural swaying of the building in the
wind was powering up this little
microphone that was listening in on
things and he said they were look they
were looking at this stuff they're like
we don't know anything like this yes
completely new stuff and that we found
it
and yet building I like I mean I don't
love but it's like it's kind of cool
it's cool yeah like I just don't kill me
or us
you don't even like the hope is we just
boat would they have their thing and we
and it's just like mutually assured
destruction like a arms race of
Technology because that's what's gonna
happen the amount to use the cloud yes I
I know like I don't use it for important
stuff yeah
but I use it for like my apps yeah my
apps are backed up in the
Recordings are backed up in the cloud
sets sets yeah but there's like no
photos or video it's just a bit like I
don't know man the kids [ __ ] crazy I
mean we're we're we're getting down to
some very strange place with the cloud
what stuff B yes in the air and the
amount of trust
it takes the presumption that will just
never run out of energy mm-hmm and will
never run out of the ability to happen
in the cloud it's like I don't that
seems presumption I I'm not even like a
doomsday person but I just feel like
it's like the difference between how men
dress in public and how women do it and
like on AB night out women are wearing
heels and guys are dressed in case they
have to fight I'm still like we will do
this thing in the mirror like yeah I'll
[ __ ] [ __ ] you huh like that's how I
feel with technology where I'm like what
do I have a back-up plan for this even
people with like Wi-Fi door locks I'm
like I don't know man no no no man I
don't know if the Wi-Fi goes out yeah
like please be care I don't I don't know
what the what the negative scenario is
but even my garage in my place and I
live in like a townhouse thing and there
was a power outage the gate won't open
and like oh no there's no really there
was a fails there was a release that
somebody a better person than I figured
like come over I didn't have a [ __ ]
plan but someone figured out like you'll
open a hatch and then there's a chain
and you got to pull the chain and it was
like okay but it wasn't it wasn't easy
right like you know it's the Doomsday
thing it's like well this guy yes guys
been on my show several times who's just
done recently and he's one of the main
proponents of this theory that something
somewhere around twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago hit the earth and
[ __ ] up everything and probably reset
civilization killed off the vast
majority of us 12,000 that were not yet
corresponds at the end of the Ice Age
there's a lot of physical evidence for
it and increasingly we're seeing more
and more evidence in terms of ancient
cultures that existed far before to
twelve thousand eight hundred years ago
they really didn't understand that they
thought people were just
hunter-gatherers back then now they're
finding evidence of things like it's a
place called gobekli tepe which is a
giant these huge monolithic structures
that are made out of stone carved like
two huge columns yeah that don't seem
like they were made by hunter-gatherers
it seems like there was probably some
sort of a lost civilization and they
know that this all happened somewhere
around that time somewhere around 12,000
years ago so it can happen again and if
it does happen again our stuff is on
digital now which is even weirder it's
it's weirder than books right we have
books but the vast majority of most of
the data that we all keep and share we
share on phones and on computers yeah
and we can't read it we can't read it
without programs I don't know the first
thing about you know I mean like I don't
know anything about
[Applause]